hello reject nation it's Greg al-baqir
and John Humphrey over here so today
we're gonna check out the trailer for a
quiet place oh boy
this is a horror movie directed by John
Krasinski from the office and starring
his hot wife and talented actress Emily
line before we do that we wanted to even
mention to our video sponsor Stardust
Stardust is this great app that we've
been using regularly we're catching up
on the Punisher right now we've been
posting our reactions over there this
app basically allows you to do 30-second
reactions for any film TV show or
trailer it's a wonderful app that I love
using because I love the idea of
30-second reviews and it's the app that
really allows it for the quick reactions
to quick opinions on a movie especially
brevin when you're leaving the feeder
before our videos out this is a great
app to use a lot of your favorite
youtubers are using it so download the
app and follow us at the real rejects
people anyway let's go to a quiet place
John Straczynski is visual style
science ticket of a hearing aid
oh he's in it too
[Music]
good reveal Oh weird Oh
[Music]
[Music]
it makes me uncool
[Music]
oh Platinum Dunes I guess that makes
sense after 13 hours whoo I was not
expecting to be so drawn to this when I
first heard about it I mean it is not
what I was expecting John Krasinski to
be doing Tony McGuire good choice oh
yeah I forgot to mention overripe a tree
on one of our roar tiers is that
whatever video you request we must do
whether it be a reaction or a discussion
whatever Tony McGuire requested a quiet
place I was like for you buddy we'll do
it that's its trailer it's great teaser
trailer that's a fantastic teaser
trailer that's a trailer that really had
me hooked the whole time yes it's got a
lot of mystery you got a lot of intrigue
it look menacing and unsettling yeah
creepy it seems like it will have that
deliberate type of pacing this visual
style reminds me a little bit of like
David Sandberg well it's very like Lisa
and this is very composed very smelly a
very you know it looks shot similar to
it comes at night like the like what
joel edgerton was to bloom house yeah he
might be to platinum dude yeah yeah yeah
yeah I always find an interesting one
like a husband and why team up on a
project together yeah yeah and this
looks like one hell of a fun project to
do together yeah because they happily
have a kid or they have a kid or
children in real life yeah the
performances look really good and I like
a good body language performance yeah
everyone in this is a body like a movie
yeah what a unique concept looks like a
better version of the village to me it
comes to night Meets The Village it's
kind of the vibe I'm getting where
they're hiding out in this in this home
and then and there in the woods a
concept of it is so interesting that you
must remain silent and yeah it gets you
a tree like what's that monster because
I was a scary image when you see those
lines on the wall it's a big boy oh yeah
that was super scary they're clearly
traumatized as hell a damn kid had to
knock over that lamp and start a fire
kids and that's why if you want to
survive you killed the kids first kids
are loud
yeah it's kids men it's hard they're
hard to manage I don't know how they got
this far there's not believing and then
some kind of we
monster scenario it's produced by
Michael Bay oh yeah I was just thinking
of the movie dune dude John Krasinski's
gonna direct dune yeah if I may give
some criticism because they are
incredibly quiet in this film too quiet
in the trailer anyway I mean they're
playing Monopoly and you and here's I go
near that yeah you know you don't hear
dropping
apparently you can't even make that
noise what if they fart yeah what they
have to go to the bathroom
be a problem they have to pee be a
problem on the like a soundproof
bathroom bunker what if they snore bump
into something so it sounds kind of
ridiculous a little bit put it in that
perspective now the rules of this movie
have to make clear on just how quiet one
must be I'm gonna be like this is
ridiculous or not factoring in certain
things
yeah there are a lot of sounds to be
made in life and there are a lot of
things that are louder than you think
they are I think that could be a really
great tool for suspense but yeah it
could also be one of those things really
like wait a minute how are you being so
sorry yeah how did nobody here that had
they heard that you know yeah it's gonna
require a lot of keeping track like when
they're making dinner that has to make
some noise unless they've thought of
that man unless they have ways of
protecting against when they know they
have to make noise who knows but I'm
most likely gonna watch this movie John
Krasinski directing I'm always
interested when an actor I respect is
directing something I love Emily Blunt
the premise in the trailer really didn't
treat the hell out of me I can't wait to
check this movie out and review it but
first put up our reaction on the star
dust at people that's right away thanks
start us well thank you Tony McGuire you
guys can subscribe to the real rejects
please click that notification bell you
can follow us on social media download
and follow us at the Stardust app take
care people